Fans of the Wachowski's sci-fi classic have
known for a while that "The Matrix" franchise is
getting a fourth installment. What's more, Lana
Wachowski is set to direct, and Keanu Reeves,
Carrie-Anne Moss, and a slew of other stars of the
original movies will make their glorious return in
"The Matrix 4." The movie will also feature
some brand new additions to the cast, from
Jessica Henwick and Neil Patrick Harris to Yahya
Abdul-Mateen II. Oh, and if you're expecting new,
cutting-edge camera tricks, such as the original
movie's groundbreaking "bullet time," don’t
worry — Henwick has already teased there will be
plenty to be excited about on that front, as well.
Warner Bros. just dropped a
heaping helping of "Matrix 4" data
at CinemaCon, proving once and for
all that the movie isn't just some
plot by a bunch of machines that use
your hopes and dreams as a battery.
With the exception of the 1999 original,
the 2003 animated "The Animatrix," and a
bunch of video games, many installments in
"The Matrix" franchise have a penchant for
alliterative titles. The second and third movies
in the series, both of which premiered in 2003,
were called "The Matrix Reloaded" and "The
Matrix Revolutions," and even the 2001
documentary about the making of the original
movie is known as "The Matrix Revisited."
Warner Bros. has now revealed that "The
Matrix 4" will follow the tradition,
and its official title is "The Matrix
Resurrections." Speculations about this title
have actually been going on for quite a while,
to the point that Slashfilm jokingly predicted
it way back in 2009. Besides giving huge credit
to Slashfilm for nailing that one, the name is
pretty fitting considering that it's essentially
resurrecting "The Matrix" franchise. There's also
the fact that Keanu Reeves and Carrie-Anne
Moss are set to return in "Resurrections,"
and their characters died pretty conclusively
in "The Matrix Revolutions." This means that
in one way or another, the characters will find
their way back from beyond the veil, hopefully
in a way that allows them to re-enter the fray
while already wearing their iconic sunglasses.
The title reveal, incidentally, also falls in line
with the screening "leak" that dropped in June.
The anonymous Twitter account behind the leak
also stated that "The Matrix Resurrections"
is thematically close to "The Matrix Reloaded."
It remains to be seen whether this is the case.
The title reveal of "The Matrix Resurrections"
would be exciting news in its own right,
but as The Hollywood Reporter notes, Warner
Bros. also used their CinemaCon platform
to screen the first trailer for the
movie. As you'd expect, the trailer,
which will presumably drop online before long, is
full of massively exciting, mind-bending stuff.
Reportedly, the trailer shows Reeves' character
back in his everyman Thomas Anderson mode,
suppressing his nagging feeling that the world's
slightly off with a steady diet of blue pills
and sessions with his therapist. There's a curious
meeting with Moss' apparently equally amnesic
character, and an encounter with Abdul-Mateen's
suspiciously Morpheus-like character.
Cue red pill, martial arts training,
and amazing Neo powers — which,
apparently, allow Keanu to control
missiles with his mind this time.
If much of this seems very reminiscent of the
original "The Matrix," it's likely intentional,
because apart from the usual
"What is the Matrix?" shenanigans,
there's clearly another layer of existential
terror lying underneath the surface. Supposedly,
there's a mirror shot that shows an
older and younger Thomas-slash-Neo,
and the fact that pretty much everyone in the
world is terribly interested in their phones
might mean something awful, as well. Once this
trailer officially drops, we’ll be back with a
video breaking it all down with the easter
eggs, and small details you know and love.
"The Matrix Resurrections" is currently
slated to premiere on December 22.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Matrix
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don’t miss a single one.